big news that just broke I don't know
who's aware of this yet but there's a
huge story a few hours ago President
Trump fired
FBI director James Comey fired him yeah
apparently Trump still hasn't forgiven
Comey for making him president I hate
this freaking job like you bought me a
pony now I gotta feed it I know that's
crazy though that just happened yeah
really weird why don't honey stuff
happening today former President Obama
he's talking now he's today he was gone
for a while you know he was sound like
an episode of The Bachelor vacation yeah
it was on islands and boats him handing
people roses well today former President
Obama said you get the politicians you
deserve yeah when the bartender tried to
cut him off Obama said I'm fine
[Applause]
former acting Attorney General Sally
Yates testified yesterday that was big
in her testimony Sally Yates said she
warned White House officials about Mike
Flynn being compromised by the Russians
she did yeah
gates also tried to warn Mike Pence but
every time she entered the room he
yelled out temptress she exposed her
ankle yesterday Kim jong-un hurled a
series of insults at Barack Obama and
Hillary Clinton yeah your neighbor
lady's story Fox News has finally found
its replacement for Bill O'Reilly
the un's actor premieres doesn't really
roll off the job doesn't it no stick
around for the UN this week this is
crazy this week a Toyota Landcruiser set
the record as the world's fastest SUV
after reaching 230 miles per hour
amazing
apparently somebody was really late to
their kids soccer game that did well
enough you gave me enough to proceed
Nathan it was like strongly that was
called bread crumb laughter huh here's a
little something for you there you go
yesterday a brawl broke out at a Florida
airport after Spirit Airlines canceled
several flights giant brawl broke out to
restore control Airport police were
forced to fire Cinna bonds into the
crowd
I bet would I bet with the right
velocity a Cinnabon could knock you on
your ass yeah those are big what a way
to go though what a way to go good news
a senator made history this week by
breastfeeding in the Senate chamber yeah
yeah the the bad news it was Mitch
McConnell
what what's the problem what was that
that's the baby breastfeeding what what
you didn't like that okay my own people
okay I don't listen I'm gonna listen to
a guy wearing that sweatshirt Charlie
Brown's EKG all right listen
[Applause]
let's go we have a our moral executive
producer isn't here tonight so we have
these guys sitting in good job these are
just random people
Tracy Keene
not something I don't know Jeff Rossi
has been out now for two days I know
well they thankfully the temp agency
sent over tonight doing fine for Jeff
Ross he had some bad soup and we might
not make it but anyway
you